[Music]
is
a
[Music]
is
h
[Music]
well hey what's going on what's up Tammy
Woo look how yeah told
you that [__] looks good yeah we changed
up the background move don't go this way
no go this way little bit there you go
there you go he's moving me around
against by will yeah you can always kind
of okay don't [__] my drink up okay yeah
yeah just trying to get everything this
is the new set yeah this is the new set
yeah we just basically moved the desk
that this used to be on like out so it
SP in a different wall I could uh lower
the light a little bit see what happens
I don't know I kind of liked it like
that yeah where's Spock Spock is Fox
there he's right there you can kind of
see him except my big fat heads in the
way or my chairs in the way is what it
is maybe you should put Spock in the
background too so everyone's not freaked
out we'll move there in a
bit so he can also be on the show there
he is when his heads got
off wor about SP right now Spock was on
the show for
years we'll put him we'll put him in the
another Corner yeah he's still there
he's still there he didn't get moved
nothing got moved we just move the
computer for our other Endeavor cuz we
didn't want to keep moving the [__] back
and forth yeah this is the [__] this
is The Sex
Dungeon The Sex
Dungeon right yeah it's working out good
working out good yeah so uh yeah John
said digging the new digs and Decor yeah
like I said it's the same room that was
always there before but you camera
couldn't see we're just facing a
different angle because we moved the
camera to the other like perpendicular
to where it was before and I think if
you look in that mirror in between us on
the wall there I think you can see the
damn the [__] cing fan rocking back and
forth yeah you can yeah that ceiling fan
is really CLK clonk clonk yeah you can I
can see it yeah you see the ceing I can
see it it's okay we'll just tell people
we could have told a demonic face
Disney's Haunted House sure man that's
what I thought it was like there's
[__] ghost in there yeah people start
to show up now Tam's in yeah yeah it's
Monday night where like I said normally
we you know Well normally we a couple
weeks ago we stopped doing The Haunting
Mondays but now we're doing movie
reviews on Mondays and today this
afternoon we went and saw Meg 2 the
trench this was pretty good that pretty
good I liked it I think I liked it
better than the first one I think I
might have as well it's funny because I
was I watched like some other uh reviews
of it real quick and like a lot of
people seem to not like it as much
because they thought it was boring or
they thought that it was not enough um
monster fisticuffs like not enough
action uh what the [__] are they talking
about but I was like well I mean now it
does take until the third act for like
most of the monster [__] to happen but
that's okay I didn't mind it yeah what
what it is is that you can watch this as
a standalone you don't have to see the
first one you can just go see this yeah
so cuz I didn't remember much about this
it build it builds up real um like a
classic horror Adventure sci-fi it
doesn't give it starts off 65 million
years ago and shows you some dinosaurs
yeah because you had to have dinosaurs
you gotta have that you gotta establish
some [__] and then later
on they go down into the [__] trench
this Mariana Trench thing and they find
out that there's a lot more [__] alive
down there than just the Megalodons
there's [__] dinosaurs and
[__]
shopus [__] it's I think it was just
an octopus I don't it was just a big ass
yeah I'm calling a shark bu cuz it's in
a shark movie every review that I've
seen it it called it the Kraken so I
guess it was like a kraken yeah and it
was it was
it it it's just what's funny is I'm
watching this and go you know what this
is basically a too Godzilla Gojira movie
it's real because if you looked at the
if you looked at the old some of the
Gojira movies they were they were edited
in a in a way so it was Japanese cast
and some Western cast members in there
and it's like an international thing
happening and there's monsters coming
out of the sea and there's a little kid
a Kenny you know it's kind of like that
and it it's like that except it's us and
China basically Jason STM he's playing
this heroic role tough guy which he he's
good at that you know what I mean
likeing uh he's representing the British
you know like kind of like the [__]
tough working class British man and they
got a Chinese guy on there that's kind
of like a Chinese hero guy I don't know
if he he's probably in some other act
Chinese action movies he's good in it
too he's a little more brainy though uh
and he does do some com some some
comedic things almost kind of like
Jackie Chan you know with the acrobatics
he does a little bit of that they got a
16-year-old cutie or 15 14 14y old cutie
that they have to defend all the time to
keep her from getting killed even though
she's she's she was in the first movie I
think was she I think she was I thought
she was I thought she was the little
girl that all her parents got killed I
thought she was to but like I said it's
been a while since and the age probably
works out that's probably the same
actress and Jason States's kind of
taking on kind of like a a father role
for
and and a lot of the action sequen is
it's about protecting that girl about
half of them but that's that's actually
pretty good good
because this movie's targeted also the
teenage boys so instead of putting a
candy in there going gar who's a little
[__] Japanese boy in shorts at least
it's a girl at least he's 14 and she's
if you're a 16 or 17 year old boy she's
datable okay Kenny wasn't datable okay
so they they they KY look KY was from
The Gamer movies from The Gamer movies
they all seem to be named Kenny and the
the [__] shorts were too short on
them boys [__] back in the 60s
and U they were about six annoying they
go bye gar and they knew they knew more
than what the adults knew they could
explain everything about what the
Monster needed and what it was saying
and [__] so they got rid of that they
replaced it with a 14-y old girl then
they
got
um some uh bad guys who are kind of
realistic I liked the bad guys they were
bunch of mercenaries they were um
harvesting stuff from the bottom of the
ocean that would help them make quantum
computers and [__] room temperature
superconductors and stuff and it was
worth like billions of dollars just for
a few of these crystals they were
getting those out underneath the ocean
in this uh underground base that they
had a secret underground secret
underground base wow I'm that's pretty
good if you can build all that in 25,000
under course that's how you run into
dinosaurs all right and [__] happens in
okay and then they got some um kind of
heroic females that are pretty competent
pretty good
and
uh the the movie was not [__] um was
the movie actually made a lot of wise
directorial decisions like killing hot
girls you know and they almost made it
but no they got killed so they kind of
was good at giving you a sense that
everybody was at
risk yeah cuz a lot of people a lot of
people did get killed in yeah so it's
not super gory like considering I mean
it's PG-13 I'm pretty sure yeah
so it's not it's not like they're going
to show people like chewed up or nothing
and the movie does a lot of crossover
stuff that I liked it it homages a lot
of other movies and this one has really
omag a lot of underwater which was a
good movie I lik underwater a lot of the
walking on the [__] surface of the
ocean floor in pressure suits being
while you're being attacked by monsters
you got to walk across you know and it's
a long way what was it six six six they
say I thought they said it was 4 km it
was four km
and and their [__] face plate on one
of them was cracking and from the
pressure and it's just you know and then
they start omajin the first
movie they go to [__] Chinese
Pleasure Island or what was it happy it
was called Fun Island Fun Island alth
happy Island would have been yeah it has
it has a lot of funny [__] in there you
know fun Island they got some American
tourists in there and some Chinese
tourists and they make sure to show like
all these
middle-aged uh uh [__] Posh Chinese
uh htis you know who have money and
implants and [__] and it's funny you
know I mean an the American [__]
guy's all slobby he's a slob and he
tries to [__] pick up on him with
[__] crude [__] they're like e like
that he she literally is like e yeah
like I agree
um just the the movie is a movie it's
like a summer movie you go and watch it
you don't have to think about it it's
just
entertainment and it was pretty good I
thought I like yeah it's just a big dumb
dumb fun fun yeah killer shark movie
well and not just killer sharks like I
said because it's like not only do we
have we don't just have like the one
Megalodon like from the first movie now
you have three of them and actually one
of them was in they had had in captivity
and then it escaped yeah and then they
had two other ones that came up from it
was a whole situation they came up from
the the bottom and then you had like a
giant octopus and then you had like
these little dinosaur things yeah they
look like a salamander with a bunch of
teeth kind of they live in the ocean and
on the surface yeah they're like yeah
they're just the thing they made
up it's just a I mean it might be kind
of like a sort of real thing but it's
like I don't know if they'd still be
swimming around down there well cuz we
were saying on the way home I was just
kind of like well if they live down in
this trench like all of this time I
don't think they would have feet anymore
like they wouldn't be able to like
breathe
air you wouldn't think yeah you're not
supposed to question any of this [__]
it's just it's it's redonkulous well
yeah and like you were saying like the
whole scene of Jason STM like oh I can
swim around for 60 seconds yeah if I
just clear 25,000 feet like without a
pressure suit yeah he said everybody
else died from the [__] when the
pressure suit failed but he can go out
there and just what did he do he blew
out through his sinuses to equalize the
pressure he's okay or something well for
a little while but he did yeah and they
showed some blood pop out and that's not
what would happen in that pressure You'
just be [__] instantly crushed well
cuz like I said but it's Jason Stam
they're just trying to show like what a
big [__] badass yeah your lungs are
an empty space the pressure would only
Jason ston do that you would implode I
did like that at least one person
imploded yeah cuz if you're get look if
you're going to make a movie set 25,000
feet under the ocean one person at least
one person better implode yeah you
better write that into your script right
now yeah was a girl Sheed and they were
looking into her [__] they're like
[__] and I was kind of like
[__] it looked good too they showed just
enough they didn't show because they
couldn't it's PG but but they showed
enough to where you knew what happened I
particularly liked the shot like from
inside the shark's mouth like while it
was eating all the people at fun Island
you know what I mean like you could kind
of see him go to the mouth like [__] you
know I liked that a lot but yeah so yeah
they did homage a lot of movies like I
said particularly underwater but that
wasn't like the whole movie that was
just like the beginning I think what um
what a lot of people thought because at
the beginning a lot of it is kind of you
know the plot is sort of about corporate
Espionage essentially yeah is what it is
yeah because there's this you know the
the Chinese guy he's kind of like the um
the head of this like big ocean uh
oceanographic uh you know exploration
company yeah and they're just doing it
like to save the oceans and everything
like that but it turns out that there's
like this secret base under there where
they're mining all the [__] they're not
supposed to be there and so they're all
like a bunch of mercenaries and and then
the The oceanographic Institute has like
a mole and you know so there's a lot of
that kind of stuff going on in the
beginning and like I said I think that
was kind of what people complained about
you know it's like well we just want to
see giant sharks eat people but I was
like well you can't have a whole movie
of giant sharks I mean you can but not
no I thought the movie uh yeah I did I I
thought I thought the movie Built Well
on the lore of the first one they even
have some callbacks the same dog from
the [__] that that that surv the
shark attack for the Meg attack from the
first movies in this one so and there's
a lot of just part of that fun Island a
lot of it you know was kind of like a
kind of like an homaging the scene where
the Meg is on the Chinese beach in the
first movie which that was that's pretty
they're trying to basically what they're
doing is they homage in Jaws when they
do that one well yeah and the thing
about it too is that if you're going to
have something like that happen you're
just like oh my God like look at all
those potential snacks so it's just kind
of like if you want like a Bunch people
eating cuz it's like look we can only
kill so many people it's like not a
giant cast we can only kill so many
people like in this like small group of
people so we're going to need to go
somewhere else there's like a whole
shitload of other people that these
sharks can eat and the octopus cuz the
octopus [__] up some people too
desert's asking if [__]
cthulu no you got to see uh you want to
see underwater if you want that one yeah
that was definitely they didn't call it
cthulu in underwater but that's pretty
much what it was this one does have a
giant octopus in it though yeah I did
like the Giant Octopus I mean it is very
CGI you know what I mean like all the
sharks and everything like that but it's
pretty good though but you know that's
okay special effects are pretty good in
it yeah the acting's actually pretty
good in it for the type of movie that it
is they went a lot more cuz I feel like
the first one had some humor in it but I
feel like this one kind of leaned more
in that direction like a lot more humor
especially the one guy um the the one
kind of like uh like heavy set black guy
he was kind of like the comic relief and
he was actually like pretty funny I
thought yeah he was doing martial arts
the Desert Eagle yeah he didn't have a
hell of a lot of things he might have
been in the first movie too but but like
I said it was the first movie was 2018
which was um which we saw in the theater
but I don't remember much about it did
we see it twice we saw it once I think I
think we just saw it one time I remember
liking it but it's like I don't remember
because before we did this review like I
watched uh the horror Channel spooky
astronauts she actually did a recap of
the first movie like you know before you
go see the second one and like when I
was watching it I was like wow I don't
remember a single thing about I don't
remember this that or the other thing I
don't remember anything about it what's
funny about this movie is that it's
definitely also made to include the
Chinese
market but really this movie is very
American this is like an old school
American action adventure
sci-fi kind of movie I not sci-fi
Adventure horror Thriller I
guess um just
the writing the the
storytelling the edit it's just kind of
like a old school tample type movie yeah
like I said it's not just kind of turn
your brain off of the door and just like
watch this [__] I didn't you know what I
didn't realize until I was like looking
into this was that this is actually
based on a novel that came out in 1999
and I think the guy that wrote the novel
um his name was Steve Alton I think and
he might have written like eight of
these things like about the Megalodon
shark type of thing so I don't know I
mean this looks like it's doing okay
like MoneyWise so Jason STM said that he
was open to doing a third one they
didn't super leave the end of this open
for a third one but they could make a
third one I mean they sort of did a
little B the villain woman you know
you're not really sure she
died I mean you're led to assume she
died I guess she had a gun when they
were D driving true and uh she was still
shooting when when the when the you
never saw her body that was never
confirmed she possibly could have killed
those two dinosaurs cuz they they just
had her by the foot that's true so yeah
maybe she lived and she could do some
more she can come back Ben said he just
saw the Meg he liked it I don't were you
talking about Meg one or Meg two because
we they're they're both good if you
haven't seen them yeah yeah I remember
the first one being fun like I said I
didn't remember much about it now
because it was like 5 years ago that we
saw that so I don't remember much about
it it was just like a big dumb fun
eventually
eventually be able to get these in a box
set well sure also another thing that I
didn't realize and maybe like horror
nerds like me will be excited about this
I didn't realize this movie was directed
by Ben Wheatley now Ben Wheatley is a
British guy and horror nerds will know
him because he does weird ass horror
flicks like usually kind of like weird
slow bur kind of [__] like he did a
field in England he did um kill list he
did in the Earth I think all of those
I've reviewed on like over on my other
channel so this is I was actually
surprised when I I was like wait Ben
Wheatley that Ben weatley like kill list
Ben weatley that's crazy so yeah same
guy which is because this is like
nothing like his usual movies not what
that I'm used to anyway Stan was looking
good in it he didn't take his shirt off
we don't know what his condition is the
che you know how guys are what is his
status right now we don't know Tom leans
over to me were watching the movie and
he says is he
good-looking he asks me well there was a
reason why I asked that okay because I
had heard guys talking about this Mo
this movie a couple days ago and there's
a lot of um controversy I think it's
false [__] controversy about Jason
State them at his his wife his wife's I
think is 22 she's like a model she's
gorgeous and some people going like and
it's women mostly hating on this
situation probably women in their 30s
and 40s cuz you know they lost him you
know he [__] went for the younger
woman they're saying like what's an ugly
[__] do it like that doing with
that young beautiful woman I'm going
like I'm looking at him going like that
dude doesn't look ugly to me yeah I was
like he looks tough as Nails you know
what I mean and young women like that
kind of look and he's got status and
money that's [__] Jason St what are
you talking about yeah Jason [__] you
know a model really doesn't doesn't
really mean anything in Hollywood those
girls don't have any money not
really and there were times in the
United States where if a girl was a
model man that was for one of these
agencies that was like a Ford agency and
[__] that was a euphemism for hooker
that those were the dating those were
the [__] escort services for the
[__] celebrities with the [__]
modeling agencies you know so you're not
saying you know like a street hooker but
you know that's where celebrities dated
girls and I think they [__] paid the
[__] for the date through the
agency you know like a bride service
maybe or a girlfriend service that's
prably still going on doesn't mean
they're bad girls it's just that's how
celebrities can't date normally you know
Girls Gotta make money yeah you know and
those dudes aren't losers you know what
I mean like I said we can't judge the
[__] we do for money
yeah hey man we're honest about what we
do that's true uh speaking of which uh
thank you very much Aaron Aaron gives a
very generous super chat love the new
set thank you very much yeah like I said
this this has actually been like this
the whole entire time been for years but
it's just that you couldn't see it
because it was like perpendicular to
where the computer was but yeah we just
moved it to facilitate like the other
show and I was like well that's kind of
a nice background too I always like that
background better than that one it is
nice I love those curtains actually I
got those off Amazon they weren't even
that expensive I set that lighting up
folks that lighting all this lighting I
yeah we wanted it to look all like
satanic back there and [__] got our
[__] lights up here I'll show you
guys what it looks like watch my drink
God damn it oh my God remember that
throw up yeah okay there's one light on
the
tripod that's what we're looking at
there's
y'all ring light there's
Jen there's Jen yeah Jen's booty there
light there's Spock my Booty's in the
chair yeah and then there's a light back
there and then look at that [__]
look at that Charming handsome
nah anyway you were just talking about J
and like I was like I guess like Jason
STM I but in no universe is Jason saam
ugly in no Universe no in no Universe no
and if and um he always looked tough he
was I thought he looked cool I would say
that he was in some ways he reminds me a
little bit of like a
British [__] Sylvester Stallone he's
about I don't know though he's a lot
better looking than Sylvester Stallone I
will say that there were times when
Stallone look really good though I know
but I mean I don't know just I I just
think that I just think that
Jason maybe like a British Bruce Willis
but tougher looking than Bruce Willis
yeah I kind yeah kind like I feel like
that's more Bruce Le Willis was always
kind of like a an an American every man
you know he wasn't really fun and he
started out as a funny guy he didn't
really start out as an action but he
went into that like later on well they
put him in Die Hard that die hard won to
kind of foil all the other action movies
that had come before they had Arnold
Schwarz egger and uh speci
Stallone and they put him in there
because he had such a care such a
reputation of just being average dude so
now you got average dude but funny and
charismatic and no shoes yeah and his
feet were all cut up he didn't have a
bell right um you know what I mean so he
was not fighting those [__] thieves
from a um a position of strength but he
still made it yeah you know and that was
what the whole diard series was and that
worked like [__] Gang Busters cuz
that that movie is still beloved right
and for a very good reason because it's
an awesome movie STM kind of reminds me
of that but more amped up more closer to
Stallone well and I always like Jason
STM too because he always like I said he
seems like a tough guy but he also has
like he's kind of funny and he's
charismatic and he's and even in this
movie movie you can tell that he's not
you know nobody's taking it totally
seriously they're just having they're
leaning into it's like yeah we know that
this is this no [__] would happen like
this like you know what I mean this is a
ridiculous ridiculous premise but that's
okay we know that you know that just
have a good time like don't even worry
about it and I kind of like respect that
you know what I mean yeah Tammy said I
remember Bruce in the TV show
Moonlighting yeah I do too I do too that
that was where he got really famous and
I think that when the first Die Hard
first came out people were like Bruce
Willis in an action movie what the [__]
are you thinking and I was like well I
guess they were Geniuses because that
[__] worked out really good didn't that
movie came out that for a while that
became my dad's favorite movie he
[__] loved that movie we watch it
every Christmas yeah I think a lot of I
think die
[Laughter]
hard
cough oh no you had seen Die Hard oh
[__] man it was fighting like that it
was like real fighting you when you lose
that's what like
I'm going get you like that for in the
time he didn't even have no shoes
on he ran through the glass feed was all
cut up that's the way it would really be
yeah that's my Dad loved that [__]
movie I think a lot of people liked it
for exactly that reason because he
didn't seem like a superhero CU I think
after a while like in the 80s you know
you had movies with Arnold
Schwarzenegger like you said in silver
they almost kind of seem like
superheroes or like Supernatural in a
little like you couldn't really even
hurt them like all that much and I think
people responded well to yeah they were
archetypes right uh I remember the first
real action movie that I liked was
Commando with Arnold Schwarz and Egger
yeah and really if you watch that it's
very much like a 80s platformer video
game where there's boss fights and
you're running through [__] and it's got
a [__] soundtrack and we loved that
[__] movie I don't know if it was
copying video games from the 80s or if
video games from the ' 80s were copy and
commando but it it was kind it might
have been the second thing but I don't
know it might have been it was kind of
that same format a weird Synergy going
on I can't really remember and you can
watch Commando today and still [__]
love it you know AR's not going to get
hurt that's why you're watching it yeah
you're watching him with a bunch of guns
run through all these dudes yeah he's
like a superh he Bad Dudes that's what
you that's what you what you watched it
for are watching it for yeah cuz that
was novel in those days yeah but it got
tired after a while there a lot of them
started to come out Tammy said yeah
Bruce wasn't overly muscular yeah and
like I said I think that's what worked
so well about that because he just came
off like an every every man but he was
really smart and resourceful and so he
ended up he wasn't in bad shape though
either he just wasn't he wasn't a gym
rat right right right he was supposed
like a guy that you meet in the police
force you know just like that camp guy
said was Stallone in Annie Hall one of
the street punks outside the movie
theater I seem to remember he was but I
haven't seen that movie in a long time
so I'd have to go back and watch it
again
um Kevin Donovan said any chance you'll
take off your tank top what right now
maybe talking to you hopefully not
talking to me yeah yeah I can't you get
to pay for that I was like I don't do
that [__] for free come on
now where is
[__] we would over I had I had the
day off today so so we so we did um so
we did stream mate this morning actually
yeah we made almost 50 bucks in about 45
minutes well yeah we were only on for
like an hour yeah so I guess well that's
what like our friend has been telling us
it's like oh it's much better like in
the daytime like in the morning all
those dudes have all that energy and so
we got up this morning and went on what
what time did we go like 9:00 a.m.
actually we went in late for the [__]
morning hours I think it was 9:00 a.m.
or 9:30 or something like that no we
went in at around 10:00 oh okay and got
off at nearly 11: quarter yeah cuz we
had to leave cuz we were going to the
morning and stuff but we were on for a
little while we just kept getting hit
slammed one right from the other
[__] one thing leads to another and
[__] one dude ask for something show
starts and four other dudes [__] pile
into the show to see it if it's not
exclusive and they all start asking for
different things
and they're wanting me to rough her up
I'm roughing her up get all the
freakazoids that time of day yeah but
you got to you got to put on a good show
it's got to sound good you know what I
mean uh but you you you can't you can't
I can't hurt her yeah so it's like pro
wrestling yeah because I have theater
background I can do that kind of [__] I
trust you pow and I'm making noise you
know I'm sling her but the hands cued
yeah and it's not a full blow there's a
bunch of different ways where you can I
know he wouldn't do that
no he wouldn't do that and it's
not overly brutal it's just
spicy just spicy just spicy yeah just
spicy and that started with a British
dude wasn't it yeah yeah that was a
British dude he was the first one that
paid the first one that started he he
was he was so polite it was so I was
like wow we have really nice people yeah
he goes he goes in exclusive he didn't
turn his camera on I said you could turn
your camera on but it was Private it was
he went to private not exclusive cuz
other people jump and I said um what you
looking for he goes dud it doesn't
matter I'm just horny I'm in the office
I'm horny
yeah I was like
nice we we cuz it's afternoon over there
it's 5 hours later yeah so then like
three or four other dudes jumping then
we had another one before that some dudy
stouted all [__] pitiful could you
guys could you guys do a dick rating on
me and be honest so yeah go you know go
on exclusive turn your camera on WE
we'll give you a
rating those [__] are always
playing games games man cuz every time
they do that that [__] comes at
you look like a 40 oz beard like dude
you need to be a porn man he's like yeah
yeah we told it's like why aren't you
doing this why aren't you doing this so
you know so we put on a show for him he
stayed for quite a while yeah we got
like I said we got a couple people that
stayed like in a l for a long time yeah
but your average show is only five
minutes yeah but we have had people stay
for like 10 minutes 15 minutes uh
longest we've have is about 15 yeah
which is not bad cuz we make 59
according to Bill uh my friend Bill his
wife does it the longest show they've
ever had was an hour yeah and that dude
talked through most of it he just wanted
somebody he just wanted somebody to talk
to and uh but then the longest one that
was just like uh guess you could say
kind of like erotic activity I like that
erotic activity we need a sign that says
that he said it was 25 minutes okay was
a was the longest one yeah I think the
longest one we've done was like 15
minutes yeah
and our prices are 5.99 a minute
yeah uh what is your handle is it only
fans um we don't have an only fans
because it was too much of a pain in the
ass to get it won't let you in you can't
get in there um Tom has a fans Le but
there's nothing on it yeah uh we're on
streammate and I think it's just is it
called gen Tom cam or Tom gen cam or
something like J Tom cam I called J Tom
cam yeah and there's video for sale
there yeah but it's just genen and I
have video we have videos for sale on
many vids
that's both of us and that's both of us
yeah they let us upload both of us on
there because we had a bro you see for
some
reason this is just the way it is
whoever owns the or whoever has
registered the um the streamate account
which is me which is her only she can
put video sell video of herself she
cannot sell any videos of her co-stars
right might have some do the licensing
yeah because I think they consider it
two different things live streaming and
selling videos
so there are two the videos that we sell
there sometimes there are more than one
version of those because we've edited me
out of some of those so we could sell
them yeah uh but then the ver the
version that has me in it would be on
Min vids yeah and we're selling on Mini
vids you guys are tracking it tracking
us down in that one what's the name of
our mini vids I think that's called 13
cam just like our Twitter account what
we have a Twitter account under that too
but there's literally three photos on
there cuz Tom said he was going to run
it and he hasn't done well I had had
time he hadn't had time yet to do put
anything on there and uh the but if um
13 cam is is is on uh mini vids you'll
find us I just couldn't call it that on
streammate because they were like yeah
you can't have any you can't have any
numbers in your name that are under 18
because you they'll have people weirdos
looking for you know so what they'll do
is is um oh [__] what was I going to say
oh um on Mini vids we have 10 videos
yeah I think there's 10 up there so far
they go from probably like three bucks
up to about 20 or 15 yeah I think 15 the
shorter they are the less they cost the
better they are and the longer they are
the more they cost right there's some in
there with me and Chen together a lot of
them are just uh probably half of them
are just gen solo may' be more than
half yeah sometimes I'm running special
effects and
[__] yeah and I I did all those [__]
uh bizarre titles I titled the [__] out
of that [__] Jenny was laughing yeah
because I told him it's like because
like I said he's he's real good at that
kind of stuff so I was just kind of like
well you have to come in here and like
help me title the tit Des give me some
crazy ass titles and descriptions for
these so people will buy cuz you know
I'm a writer but it's like I she doesn't
write [__] smut right not well you
know I have but I'm not good at um
erotica and just like porn videos are
two different things you know what I
mean speaking of erotica we were at the
bookstore today and I'm in the horror
book section and was it you Tammy that
recommended that um T king fisher book
or was it Oracle I can't remember um
that's called a h the you know the house
has good bones or something like that um
they had that so I bought it because I
we just got a books a million membership
and I got like a 20% off so I bought
that [__] so I might do a review on that
next but I got to do slooh foot too by
Braum because I also bought that one but
we were in there today and I'm in the
horror book section and there was a
hardback book in there by Chuck tingle
but it wasn't erotica it looked like
from just reading the back of it it
looked like kind of like a camp slasher
like a Friday the 13th kind of thing
maybe it's not but that's kind of what
it looked like you remember the title it
was called Camp Damascus see if that's
actually him I think that's what it was
I was like yeah that's got to be so I
was like so I guess he's branching out
yeah into like writing other stuff I
know who that is well we've talked about
Chuck tingle like a lot of please look
up Chuck angle just go look out the if
you don't know who that is go look on
the Wikipedia page and just read the
titles of his erotic books and you will
have hours and hours of entertainment
just from the titles I promise look at
his
profile his author profile is a stock
photo of a dude in a [__] karate ghee
I mean he's [__] hilarious yeah it's
funny yeah Tammy said it was probably
Oracle I told you about the channel a a
great undertaking yeah that's right
that's right because I was trying I was
trying to remember because I knew that
those two recommendations were like kind
of at around the same time but um but
yeah so also since we're not even
talking about Meg to anymore but like I
said I don't want to ruin it for people
it's cuz it just came out like this
weekend I guess but you know it's just
like a big dumb fun shark move people
get we recommended it people get eaten
by octopuses people get eaten by a
little tiny dinosaur creatures yeah that
couldn't possibly exist but that's fine
if you just want to Jason STM punches
people yeah punches sharks on
purpose well there times when he could
have talked his way out of that but no
I'm a punch us too well like I said you
don't get Jason St to be in a movie if
you're like you want him to punch people
you want him to punch people and you
want him to like say [__] and you know
and he does that yep Jason he's rep
representing representing the working
class of Britain I mean he's staming out
yeah that's what you hire his ass for
yeah but yeah so here's another thing
that happened because we're going to
talk about this too here's another thing
that happened so before we went to the
movie uh the movie theater where we go
to is in this mall called what is it
called lak Square mall or something like
that it's in so it's damn near almost a
dead mall it's in leeburg yeah yeah it
it's not that it's not like Dan Bell
worthy because there are still a bunch
of stores open yeah there's not a lot of
vacancies in there it's just a very hard
it's just dumb stuff most of it's just
mostly like it's not huge yeah so that's
where the theater is that we go it's an
AMC theater and there's also a books a
million there and we always go in the
book books a million and go around and
get coffee and [__] like that however
there is also a pet smart and today we
don't always go in there CU it's right
around the corner from books of million
but we had a little while before the
movie started and Tom's like let's go
look in the pet store and I was like
okay cuz you know how that goes and they
have PetSmart has kitties for
adoption and we went in there and there
was a little kitty in there was a little
girl and she was a MX 14 months old 14
months
old and they said she just came in this
morning from hoffmire which is an animal
we've seen them but they come into books
a million like every other week and like
bring in cats they do like a big
adoption uh event like at the bookstore
so they bring them in and they try to
get people to adopt the cats so I guess
she came from there and she had been
there literally one day and we looked at
her and Tom like made eye contact with
the kitty yeah and we were like can we
she's like well you want to take her out
and like Pat her and stuff so we took
her out and like petted her and I'm
like she's so sweet and and um Tom's
like okay well we're going to go see the
movie if that cat is still here when we
come back from the movie we're we're
taking this cat yeah so we went to the
movie and then we went back to the pet
store and we looked in her little
compartment cuz I think they have like
they had like four different cats there
and we looked in her little compartment
and we didn't see her and we're like oh
my God somebody came in and got her like
in the [__] two hours we were in the
movie holy [__] and so we went and asked
some they're like Hey where's Dakota is
her name and um they're like where'd she
go and they're like well no nobody
adopted her it's like maybe she's in
there someone then the guy came and he's
like oh she's hiding like way in the
back of the thing and we couldn't see
her like from the outside so long story
short too late we got another kitty yeah
we got another kitty I can go get that
cat maybe I'll go get it you want to go
get her yeah and anybody who gives us
any money you can be the cat's god
parent
we're kind of like
um come here and this is literally we
brought the we brought the kitty home
she was totally quiet like in the Box
all the way home cuz we got we bought
like a little card just a cardboard like
cat carrier to bring her back in and
it's like about an 18m drive like from
our from the movie theater back to our
house and she was totally silent the
whole time she just sat in there like
kind of looking out the holes and we
were talking to her the whole time it's
like it's okay we're going to new house
and all this other stuff and then we
came to the house and we called Pooky
and Pooky came and like stuck her little
nose in the box and they were sticking
their nose and pook's like oh I don't
like this and then Pooky went and hit
under the
bed um oh you got her you got her here
she is you
guys there she is this is
Dakota yeah she's just like and she came
in the house and she was like all right
this is all right and she has just been
I sat out down on the floor with her and
she's just like loving all over me and
purring and rolling and showing me her
belly and she didn't hide or nothing
yeah Pookie's kind of mad but I think
hiding I kind scared of her I think
she'll get over it Pooky hissed at her
and I've never heard Pooky hiss ever so
I'm just kind of like that kind of
stressed me see look look at look at
this cat she's bur yeah you can hear it
burn it's really
loud but it's I've never she's never
been in a house maybe not like I don't
know how long she'd been at the shelter
she's only 14 months old
and she's also a Mex her tail is longer
than pookies but it's still like a like
a stub like Stumpy so that was another
thing we we talked about it's like it
would be nice getting another Ms because
their personalities would maybe cuz Max
kitties have personality plus I'm
telling you right now thank you Jeffy
Art thank you all right Jeff Jeff you
are now a God
parent look at it look at this guat yeah
yeah we literally just met her today and
we came back backing at her yeah and
she's just like yep all right I could
get used to
this she's like I don't know you that
well you don't know let's calm down now
just a little bit but yeah so I'm just
kind of hoping that Pooky will get over
it soon and they'll be friends cuz
that's why we got we were talking about
cuz Pooky is like so rambunctious I mean
she's not a kitten anymore she's six but
it's like she still acts like a kitten
she just like runs around like crazy
like Mommy play with me Daddy play with
me is name play with and beige is too
old beige is like get out of here yeah
and beige is like [__] off I don't so we
wanted like a younger Kitty that they so
they could play together you know and
they could just run around and roll
around and [__] like that so bye see you
later yeah but yeah so we weren't even
expecting to do that but it seemed like
some like The Universe telling us that
probably cuz like I said we don't
usually go in that petmart but Tom's
like let's go in the pet store and then
they were like oh that's Ma and it just
came in this morning I was like oh okay
oh Tammy you are now a God parent thank
you Tammy John gor said are you calling
her Meg oh we
should she came as Dakota we're gonna
keep it that's a good name I mean that's
she looks like a Dakota yeah that was
her name when we uh when we adopted her
so that's what they named her at the
thing and I was like she's probably used
to people calling her that so I think
it'd be weird to like change her name
but that's what we're going to call her
that's name yeah like I said she we had
such a problem naming Pooky God she had
a couple different Nam we went through
through so many names well because we
got her real name is Baby Cookie yeah
yeah and sometimes I still call her
cookie sometimes cuz she is like a
little cookie but I don't know it's just
like I always even when she was younger
I started calling her Pooky like as a
nickname because she just looks like a
Pooky to me she you know she pookies
around I don't know why that why that
name like stuck out to me but that's
just kind of what she seemed like but it
took us like forever to come up with a
name for her
I think for a while we were calling her
otter poop Otter Pop she look like an
otter for a while well and because that
little because that little tail sticks
up and it looks like the end of a
popsicle yeah so that's what we were
thinking cuz her little butt looks like
a little popsicle sticking out but yeah
so that's kind of what we were thinking
but yeah so now she's just Pooky or
pater Pooks yeah
poama Pooky doodle do whatever we just
like call her different names yeah we
call her that too just variations or
count Pula I've called her that before
too you know but yeah so I'm kind of
hoping cuz that was the one thing that
was stressing me out was that I was like
oh I don't want Pooky to be mad or think
she's getting replaced or anything like
that but I just want them to hang out so
we'll see how that goes but yeah we
weren't really going we didn't go out
expecting to like bring another kitty
home but we did so that's that's how we
do oh well uh Tammy says None of my
animals get called their real names yeah
I kind of think that that probably
happens you know they have a formal name
you never use they have a formal name
that you never use and then they just
you just call them nicknames all the
time I mean I always wanted to know the
name that the cat called itself see head
yeah I always wondered that too and I
think that's why it took us so long to
name her because I was like what does
she seem like to me like she has a very
unique personality and it's like every
name we came up with I'm like it's not
quite right cats probably just think of
themselves as me my name is
me so that's what maybe we call her come
here me I call her other things too like
you know I call her muffin or pumpkin or
something like that I call her like lots
of different things or fluff ass or no
that's more I call Beijing fluff ass I
more call Pooky like fluff
butt yeah M Bowser says Pooky will warm
up eventually I hope so I think she will
because it took a while for her and
Beijing to get along she already already
came back up here kind of like where's
that cat yeah looking for it so we'll
see I'm going to try and put like
different food down and stuff like that
because I don't want there to be like
little fistic cuffs when she's like why
is that why is that with eating my
treats you know so they they're going to
have to each have their own thing yeah
CU otherwise Pooky is going to get mad
you know what I mean but yeah so we'll
see we'll see how it goes so yeah we
have three kitties now which is okay
it's a big house they'll all get along I
think all right so are we done yeah all
right so if you don't know uh our
Wednesday night show we're doing another
True Crime show and we're doing a show
about a Florida serial killer from back
in the 70s named Gerard John schaer that
sounds familiar he was a [__] cop oh
okay I think I think I know this not
entirely sure how many people he killed
but we're going to talk about him uh
I've been wanting to do a show about him
for a while because like I said he's
Florida specific it was back in the 70s
but you know what I mean he's dead now
so don't worry about it oh my God I'm
going to find out what's happen what the
hell's going on over oh she's licking on
the plate oh okay yeah we got their
little food plates over there behind the
laptop all right so hopefully you guys
can uh can come by for that because it's
always fun doing the True Crime shows in
a [__] up sort of way so thanks for
dropping by today thanks for all your
super chats we should get new cats more
often get like [__] super
chat but yeah so we will see you guys
again on Wednesday night good night